i'm mike feeney and i'm here to answer
the internet
[Music]
philosophy i'm going going philosophy
101 here we go
if you had one free throw and if you
make it you get one million dollars but
if you miss
you never get to text again would you
shoot it
ah man a million dollar
listen i've had so many free throws in
my life where the second you let it go
you know it's wrong and that pain
that pain the second it comes off the
tip of my fingers
just going like and that's the rest of
my life i couldn't
and then you have to call people again
[ __ ] that no i can't i can't take the
shot
my [ __ ] was like short charge yeah yeah
yeah thank you
yeah and that's the one and the ones
that i think i would do well on i'd be
like nailed it and then all of a sudden
it would you know
[ __ ] rim off or it'll be like buckets
and then it would bounce you know
whatever um wow that's crazy that's a
crazy
philosophy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah philosophy do you trust your
basketball skills
here's my philosophy no i don't uh if
you were the opposite sex for a day
what would you do i don't know if i'd
get out of bed
i mean you have to you got to play with
you got to give it a spin
you know i don't know how much i'd be
interested in the vagina and the
in the shoving into me i feel like i'd
be more the tits
you know what i mean but yeah i have a
head inside me
really but you can do that now with your
[ __ ]
yeah yeah you still have a hole you
don't have tits yet
you gotta be putting syrup all over be
crazy
again philosophy this is a loose brand
of
philosophy do you say god bless you
after every sneeze
um no i don't uh i i say it
like are you talking about in public to
people i'll say it i'll say it under my
breath but i'm not gonna go out of my
way
to say but i'll do a little like you
know you like you whisper it
because yeah because the catholicism is
rooted into you you know
but here's something that i do if
somebody if i cough and somebody says
god bless you to me
i feel the need to correct them
that's the catholic guilt i grew up with
where i'm like that actually
wasn't a sneeze um but i appreciate your
blessings
yeah yeah yeah i'll take your blessings
but i don't
i don't need them i'll give you i'll
give you
two my wife always sneezes in three so i
think three is the maximum
i'll give you if i don't know you you
get one or two and then it's like
get the [ __ ] over you know what i mean
like tv
tv movie video games would you miss the
final season of your favorite tv show
you never even get to know how it ended
uh to get your favorite sports team
into the championship oh you don't win
one though
now do i have all of my previous
championships
yes you right now okay you're spoiled
[ __ ] you
yankee fan as a yankee fan i just can't
imagine uh
so i don't i guess i i guess i would
because one show is just like listen i
missed the end of the sopranos
that sucks i'll never know but then i
can you know every year for the rest of
my [ __ ] life i got to watch the
yankees not make the [ __ ] world
get out of here i would i would give it
up to get them to the sports team yeah i
would 100 good
the one that i'd i mean sopranos ending
was really kind of left
nobody wrote you know it kind of left
you hanging i'm trying to think of a
show that i was like that's a [ __ ]
great ending
there's very few they all go they go
breaking bad yeah if brave if you were
like you can find out the ending to
breaking bad
like right now if i was just like you
don't know what happened to walter white
yeah yeah the yankees won like the 2014
whatever it is but like you don't know
what happened to walter white that would
[ __ ] with you
[ __ ] that would be tough but i think it
would be worse i know more
red sox and mets fans than i do uh
breaking bad fans who want us ruin my
life you know what i mean
you gotta think about the worst type of
person you know and
you know i like that yeah oh [ __ ] this
is a breaking bad one so this is perfect
uh br mary [ __ ] y'all uh skyler white
marie schrader and uh or lydia
[ __ ] now i'm trying to remember who i
mean ty uh skyler i don't understand
people did the whole turn on her where
they were like she's a [ __ ]
and now she's the best at the end yeah
never liked her
i'm a [ __ ] first impression guy if
you're hit if you're a [ __ ] in the
beginning or a [ __ ] in the end
uh and she was awesome and she helped
him with the car wash and [ __ ] but i you
gotta you gotta kill her
marie i think she was uh she was
purple she was all the purple yeah she
stole the [ __ ] she was a
shoplifter yes that's the one you [ __ ]
because she is crazy
uh and so that would be a good and
there's something about the purple you
know there's some weird fetishes there
and plus you don't want to be married to
that that would be a nightmare so i
guess i'm being married to lydia
lydia was like this uh stevia chick who
ends up always even killing she was like
a drunk like she was like the middleman
kingpin
oh she was like so crazy yeah like she's
like she's like severe mental issues yes
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] either way
god damn it would you move in with your
crush to try and get out of the friend
zone
or you're just torturing yourself that
is cra
if you move in with a girl in the hopes
of trying
to get laid you're an idiot you move the
wrong you're moving in the wrong that
cements the fact that you're
friend-zoned
forever i have so many of my friends who
are obsessed with like girls they grew
up with and they're like as long as i
just like i'll be like the
fun uncle to their baby and then maybe
they'll realize and they just it just
it breaks my heart man see i disagree
you're
you're he's right i think
i think they're basically the only
reason she's gonna move in with you is
because she's like nah
yes because you're not because you're
not a threat see but like
you gotta turn her i think every girl i
know wants to [ __ ] a little bit
if like i was at home when i was there
you'd [ __ ] me
like there's somebody yeah but if you
just
[Music]
but then you have then you have to have
that conversation the next day where
like it was a terrible mistake
it'll never happen again yeah and then
guess what
right you got some martinis
and that's how you catch a me too
[Laughter]
what should you do if you find your
significant other on a dating app
uh you gotta break up with her right
immediately or him i mean if they're on
a dating app they're actively
looking it's not even like i'm putting
the feelers out there they have set up a
profile they found their best picture
and the best lighting they've wrote in
about me section there's no way
what if it's like you just made it
official within the last
month and you know that she wasn't like
dating around a lot the last six months
because you've been
you know sure kind of like that
i guess that's a little stick you'd have
to see how active she is i would
probably be a full psycho and have a
friend or just make up a dummy account
and message her and be like hey
ready you available let's see what's
going then play that i'll catfish her
with me
would you rather [ __ ] a professional
porn star or an amateur only
fans girl i mean this isn't even a
question to me
it's always the amateur only fan you
can't [ __ ]
a porn star what are you talking about
first off the confidence you have
in your dick to think that you could
[ __ ] a porn star first off you know
they're always faking it so it doesn't
seem like there's going to be any
authenticity the only fans girl
needs this you understand like this is
this is like a patreon first she needs
that content coming in
so she's going to put on our best
performance the porn star is just going
through the motions you know if you have
the ability to have sex with anyone
but they get cancer right after oh no
do you take yourself off the market or
just kill people
wow that's
that there i mean i'll tell you this the
cancer rate's going up
because i'm sorry i mean listen i might
i have to do it at least once
maybe that's where i just go on a [ __ ]
my enemies tour
you know i go yes i'm batman yeah i just
i just grovel my way in plead beg and
then once i get
you know to [ __ ] him that's it i would
do that i think the
catholic guilt in me and again i keep
saying that i'm not a catholic person
but i was raised with that irish
catholic guilt in me
it would definitely it would definitely
haunt me but at the same time you'd be
like well i gotta get a nut
yeah you know what the worst part is
it's not even like
it's not like boom you're dead right
away but you walk out of that apartment
like with a smirk like
the next six to nine months ain't gonna
be good for you yeah yeah like yeah you
just look at her and you go as you're
walking out you go enjoy that hair while
you got it
the most popular game from barcelona
sports now available in the palm of your
hand questions as [ __ ] up as you are
in your pocket download answer the
internet